Nos dicen que: "El triángulo ∆A'B'C' es la
imagen del triángulo ∆ABC con una homotecia
cuyo centro es P y el factor de escala es 3/4.
¿Qué opción muestra correctamente el triángulo
∆A'B'C' con un trazo continuo?" Pausen el video
y traten de resolverlo por su cuenta. Muy bien,
antes de ver las opciones, me gustaría que
pensáramos en cómo sería realmente esa homotecia.
Tenemos que el centro de homotecia es P y que el
factor de escala es de 3/4, entonces una forma
de pensar en esto es que, independientemente
de qué tan lejos esté cada punto de P, ahora
estará a 3/4 de esa distancia, pero en la misma
recta, así que sólo voy a estimarlo. Entonces,
si C está aquí, la mitad estaría a esta
distancia, entonces 3/4 estaría justo ahí,
por lo que C' debería estar ahí. Si tenemos esta
recta que conecta B y P de esta manera, veamos,
la mitad de eso está aquí, 3/4 va a estar
ahí, por lo que B' debe estar aquí, y luego,
en esta recta, la mitad es más o menos aquí. Sólo
lo estoy aproximando. Entonces, 3/4 estará ahí.
Ahora, A' debería estar aquí, por
lo que A'B'C' deberían verse así,
lo que podemos ver es exactamente lo que tenemos
en la opción C, la opción C parece correcta,
así que voy a poner un círculo alrededor y
seleccionarlo así, pero asegurémonos de entender
por qué estas otras dos opciones no son correctas.
La opción A parece ser una homotecia con un factor
de escala de 3/4, las dimensiones de cada uno
de los lados de este triángulo parece que es
aproximadamente 3/4 de lo que era originalmente,
pero no parece que el centro de homotecia sea P,
aquí parece que el centro de homotecia es
probablemente el punto medio del segmento AC,
porque parece que todo está a 3/4 de la distancia
que estaba hasta ese punto. Entonces hay otro
centro de homotecia en la opción A, el centro
de homotecia no es P y es por eso que podemos
descartarla. Y luego, para la opción B, aquí
parece que se equivocaron en el factor de escala,
en realidad tienen mal el centro de homotecia
y el factor de escala, parece que todavía están
usando éste como centro de homotecia, pero este
factor de escala está mucho más cerca de 1/4
o 1/3 que de 3/4, por eso también podemos
descartarla. Nos quedamos con nuestra elección C.